[cameraman]  How do you feel
when you wear it?
[Anna]  It feels like invisibility cloak.
When you are
traveling through checkpoints,
it's a lifesaver.
[Ole]  The border to Syria is closed.
[dogs barking]
The plan is to smuggle ourselves in.
[Anna]  Nothing compares
to being on the ground...
in the level of investigation
that you can conduct.
[Fred]  In darkness, abuse takes place.
I see our job
as putting a bit of a brake on that.
[Peter]  With our emergency approach,
we changed the game of human rights.
We're closer to
criminal investigators.
[Ole]  After the 10th time
they've heard the bombs dropping,
people get used to it.
I would not get used to it.
[Anna]  He's 12 years old.
The idea that you or anybody else can die
is such an abstract.
-They bombed Azaz just half an hour ago.
-What?
Is it a good idea to go there?
[bomb exploding]
Every person who told me their story,
I owed them their moment in court.
Our evidence is overwhelming
that the forces of the Serbian police
and the Yugoslav Army
purposefully targeted civilians.
It was horrifying talking to the guy
you were tracking for 10 years.
[Anna]  People are being killed.
Thousands of people
have been detained and tortured.
We need to do something right now.
You meet somebody on the ground,
a witness, a victim,
an incredible activist,
and you feel that
if they haven't given up,
how on earth do you have the right
to give up?
[guns firing]
We have to be very careful
because, I mean, they're armed.
It's nice to be on the right side,
and it's nice to fight back.